hi I'm Sarah and today is a good day
props it's already 2:00 p.m. guess I
lost track of time get it because lost
is a theme of today's show I'm not a
good singer I'm sorry I almost forgot I
need my special get-up-and-go drink
that's the cut business maybe you've
lost an expensive lipstick your marbles
or the will to go on
losing [ __ ] is the thread that binds us
all together I've never lost anything
Oh see oh you lost your freedom by
committing acts of unspeakable horror
let's see what some other folks have
lost
when I was in third grade I was at an
amusement park and I wore retainers as
anyone who wears retainers knows you
take them out to eat and a lot of the
time they're kind of gross so you wrap
them in a napkin or something my mom
gave me her high school ring it was very
valuable obviously so I went to Burning
Man one year I decided to take a shower
one of the like community showers that
they have the hair so I took it out
wrapped in a napkin put it on my tray
and I brought my tray when I was done
eating for the trash and dumped it all
out taking a shower and my mom's ring
falls off in between into the grey dirty
Burning Man people water and just
completely freaked out so we had to
search through the giant trash bin at an
amusement park for my retainers and we
found them I boiled them and so me and
my best friend had to go into the grey
water with all the hair and the dust and
dirt and it was I don't know what else
it was so disgusting somehow we found it
and it was one of the most triumphant
moments of my life
I carimbó glad I'm not one of those
goofballs ding dong there's a man at the
door
hey what's up who are you sir dr.
lettuce here got any mail for me today
got any newspaper clippings to send to
your mom any bills to pay
actually went paperless for the
environment okay [ __ ] what's the point
of a mailman anyway yes in this digital
age
hey there's tons of good mail here this
stuff's great look at this stuff the
letter I wrote to myself that's just a
yogurt coupon people love yogurt though
really yeah yeah uh I have word textural
things like when I eat it I just like
it's like barf which is like oh dude
forgot all his mail where'd my sock go
did you see it oh you can of course
you're dead
that's creepy whoa where am I
where's Robert help I survive without my
my twin whatever he always thought he
was better than me want a tool I can't
feel my legs oh oh I don't have I don't
have legs am i bad why is it so dark I
miss feet but not Robert and why a freak
I have saved sock bless us everyone
oh there you are oh no you got a hole Oh
dingdong you've got some mail in it oh
this looks like it's from that weird
mailman Oh
peppermints dear miss I just want to say
I'm sorry for how I acted earlier my
brother passed away last month and it's
been a rough go of things sometimes I'm
totally fine and other times I'm the
saddest I've ever been please accept
these peppermints as my apology yours
forever and always
your friendly neighborhood doctor
letters PS that's a really nice blue
blanket you have hanging up behind your
little keyboard well it's working if I
can borrow it have a picnic coming up
and I should run him back huh
dear doctor letters real loss is hard
it's not fair but it's something we all
experience at one time or another the
only thing that can truly help is time
sometimes we need something to distract
ourselves from our broken hearts for you
that's your mail thank you for the
peppermints my breath smells great your
pal Sarah